[Music]
[Music]
hey
everybody yep we're not really that late
i'm late
he's a loser's mother he doesn't know
how clocks work
yeah i don't know i don't know how time
works no he doesn't no dudes you don't
know
my constant time machine i'm whatever
time i want it to be well yeah
so it's like i go it's like two minutes
till we go on and i'm like where the
[ __ ] is he and like i ran out and he's
just like farting around in the garage
yeah i had to change the [ __ ] up he was
changing some [ __ ] up in the garage
he's like how long have i got i'm like
dude we're supposed to be on like right
now
so and then he's like well no now i have
to pee and i have to do this and i have
to do that i don't pee i'm a man
i piss that's the girl i gotta take a
piss that's like
she's a girl you sit down to pee you
know
that's what you're talking about oh
girls are so lame
sit down
yeah well this started out really good
well i i will say okay so
this is gonna be i think you'll be
excited uh to hear this
but on the side track show tomorrow
night esther sent me a message
on patreon yeah and said that she would
like us to do on a sidetrack show she
wants to do
like a debate about what makes a manly
man oh [ __ ] cause her
and her husband are having a debate
about it
and they want us to get involved and
like adjudicate right
like so we can debate like once i said
well that started getting me started
early if a [ __ ] has to ask if
it's manly or not
there's an inner knowledge a man sees
something he sees another man and he's
not living up to the [ __ ] creed you
look at this [ __ ] you're like
the creed it's just something deep down
in you that knows
it just knows and even hey this goes
even with with gay men they know
they know i'll have toby on here
he'll tell you i don't know if we can
get him here on that's right yeah if
it's not
[ __ ] like masculine [ __ ] manly
then
he'll i say save it for tomorrow you
don't like it okay
go ahead go ahead but no i was laughing
because i i wrote standby tom's running
late and then tammy said what's he doing
brushing his hair
you should have said yeah i should have
said yeah that'd be a good one
grantham's hammer said i just watched
the florida project last night was that
film near y'all i don't think it was
aaron's p
everybody's been like telling me to
watch that and i really need to watch
that i thought that was filmed in south
florida but i could be totally totally
wrong
uh which is quite a ways from us
actually
but uh yeah so what are we talking about
today oh okay so
this movie here this is kind of like an
interesting
thing how this happened so we're
scrolling through
what was that noise i think it must have
been pookie jumping down out of the damn
apartment
oh okay she's like i hear you guys
talking and i want to be on tv as well
um so we're scrolling through like
looking for a movie to talk about thank
you mr robotto
what makes a manly man is magnificent
chest hair sure
yeah but it's even more manly if he
shaves that [ __ ]
how's that pokey oh that was pokey
what's up she's like yeah she's like i
can't stand like you guys being in here
and talking and not paying any attention
to me yeah yeah she was she was napping
but you know
uh but yeah so we're scrolling through
amazon prime last night
and we see this movie uh the unnamable
and it's it wasn't not listed as like
new
it was listed as like 2018 or something
like that right i think it must have
been remastered
that's uh yeah because i looked into it
a little bit because you were saying
you know man that uh the graphic on the
front like the creature like that looks
really familiar and i said it does look
kind of look familiar doesn't it
yeah and so when i looked it up yeah
this movie actually did come out and
then once we started watching it i'm
like oh obviously this is from the 80s
um this movie came out in 1988 okay
um but it went it went direct to vhs
yeah and then it was never released on
dvd
at least in the us i think in the uk it
was released like aerovidia released it
uh
on you know on dvd in the uk only
but it recently i guess it was 2018
which is why amazon prime has it listed
as that
um uh a company called what was it
called
unearthed films or something like that
and i think they picked it up and they
finally gave it a blu-ray release in
2018.
so as kind of like oh forgotten like 80s
movie or whatever
and i think the pretty much the sole
reason i think that
um this one would have got a look in was
one it's an h.p lovecraft adaptation
which is what got us interested in it
and two the creature design
uh kicks a lot of ass it's pretty good
yeah um
but other than that
not the worst movie i've ever seen but
you have to look at it in the context of
the time
in the context of the time
we probably would have rented it we
probably would have been
it's a cool cover yeah we probably would
have partially enjoyed it
but in the end been disappointed by it
strangely it's kind of aged well
over time it now kind of feels like it
belongs in with from beyond and
reanimator in a way
but kind of maybe closer to castle freak
i would say the tone is a little bit
more like castle freak
the budget's lower but it looks pretty
good
the problem with this movie really only
has two problems
it has a ponderous edit um
there's a part where two couples go into
this basically what they think might be
a haunted house
and a bunch of [ __ ] happens in there
that we didn't need to see or know they
should've just went in there and they
just showed some
scenes of them getting killed and then
to me
the two main characters one of them is
kind of like a an hp
lovecraft of like a younger version of
hp lovecraft even looks a little bit
like h.p lovecraft
they go in there and do an investigation
and they find the bodies and then
they're in this old sorcerer's house and
in the end they come face to face
with this demon it's a female demon
the costume looks really cool it's got
hair kind of like bell bottoms and
and whoever's in this costume is you
know she's an attractive woman
it's a little krampus yeah she's got
like hooves and stuff
that costume would play really well at
the castle or some of the goth clubs
that we know i think oh yeah
because i said but i i'm afraid though
that people might just think your
krampus
right oh maybe because it does look a
little crampy
but it is sort of like what they because
i reread
this is how i got to prepare for [ __ ] i
reread the hp lovecraft story this is
based on this is a very loose adaptation
um you know the hp lovecraft story is
very short it took me like 20 minutes
but hold on let me get to what the
problem was the problem is
this is a good-looking monster as soon
as you see it you get interested in it
they kill it off pretty quickly and the
monster is not a character
they gave away uh some they should have
been only
loosely adapted this from h.b love
well they did but they should have been
even more losing yeah that monster
should have actually
been a character in this movie
they should have showed that thing
pretty earlier pretty early
and had that as almost kind of like a
love interest in a way
and then it get killed maybe by
something else
even worse that's what i would have done
with this movie
yeah you know what i mean i can see that
because there was a chance to kind of
like almost redeem that
that demonic character it could have
been something like
it wasn't her fault that she was like
that maybe she was in love with one of
the guys
something almost happened maybe he was
gonna get it pregnant if she was trying
to get pregnant by him or maybe she's
trying to impregnate him
some kind of [ __ ] weird sexual angle
that's what would have happened if if
this was
a movie that had you know [ __ ]
herbert west ended or something
you know i mean it would have been more
twisted and then
something from beyond comes and kills
her
you know what i mean or she dies say
protecting the dude
something like that yeah it would have
been a lot more interesting
i mean basically okay so gave it away
yeah they gave that monster away
because the well the thing about it is
that one
i feel like the the bulk of the movie
was on
the effects not just the monster who
looks great
but also the gore effects because
actually the gore effects on this are
pretty good
um you know not not so much like the
severed head that looks really fake but
like what you know when the throats get
torn
out when hearts get torn out stuff like
that that looks uh pretty good for the
era
i just feel like okay so this the short
story
which you know this is kind of working
off of
the short story all that happens in that
is basically
kind of the [ __ ] that happens at the
beginning of this it's like two guys one
of them's randolph carter who is a com
who is a recurring character in a lot of
lovecraft stories and he's telling his
friend they're at this cemetery just
like at the beginning
of this movie and he's telling the story
about
you know this creepy house this old
timey like 18th century this dude named
joshua winthrop
you know they gave birth to this thing
his wife gave birth to this thing and it
was just like an unable
it was like a monster and then there was
like the whole thing about
um this thing was like trapped up in the
attic because like the dude like joshua
was like a warlock right
and he like made a spell to like so the
evil
monster wouldn't escape and the there
was a thing too about
how she spent so long staring out the
window
that her image became like impressed
upon the glass because that was like a
big
aspect of the short story as well
basically in the short story
it's just one of them telling the other
one the story about the old [ __ ] that
happened which like i said is at the
beginning of this with like the um
the flashback and everything and then
the two guys like go in the house they
get attacked by the thing but they don't
show it and then they live and then
later they're like oh they had like hoof
prints and like all these weird like
injuries all over them and that's like
the end
so this one is basically takes that
story
and it's like that's like the first few
minutes of it like talking about joshua
winthrop and what the monster is and
it's like there's
this legend in the house is haunted and
blah blah
but then it kind of injects it's got the
randolph carter character who's this
kind of
um he's a he's a student right a student
and he's
at miskatonic university of course and
uh he's a folklore
guy like that's his kind of uh area of
expertise i guess
and he's real um he's real like
condescending and douchey
but it's like he's also kind of like the
most interesting character because the
other ones are kind of like bland
because and i think he's supposed to be
h.p lovecraft didn't he
he might be or yeah he might be like an
author insert type of character yeah
he's supposed to be yeah because he has
a lovecraftian
face and his mannerisms are kind of
you'd think that that's the way
lovecraft would act based on what they
described
how they described him yeah because he
didn't seem like it's not minus the
racism
yeah and i'm not just putting that in
there
people that knew him even back in his
day i mean this is the thing about
[ __ ]
okay here's the deal if you're black and
you're afraid to [ __ ]
read hp lovecraft because he might be a
racist then you're not alone
because that [ __ ] was racist
against irish people
if you were there were other white
people he was racist against that's what
i mean it was like hardcore
yeah it's not just you it was pretty
much he was pretty much racist against
anybody that wasn't like wasn't it
of english english english english
descent
yeah but basically everyone else was
just like so human
yeah but he was from he was from the you
know massachusetts
yeah and he was only i think he was
fantasizing about the honky motherland
he
i don't think he'd ever been there um
his friends who knew him
said that he they got him to chill out
over time
he married a jewish woman yeah so
he did kind of lack although they
separated later but yeah
he assumed that anybody who wasn't anglo
was some kind of an enemy that would
they would hurt him basically
he had he had issues he had issues he
was a loner type dude real
uncomfortable nerdy kind of guy
any outs he was xenophobic that's a good
way to put it big time
it wasn't just racism it was xenophobia
anybody who was
he was afraid of pretty much everything
he was afraid of everybody he was afraid
of women he was afraid of anybody that
wasn't like him
yeah and here's the thing if he wasn't
like that his
his his writing wouldn't have been any
good yeah we kind of talked about that
when we talked about the hp lovecraft so
that's the thing it's like that really
like informs a lot of his right
he was afraid of everything yeah yeah
which she went away you know he said he
write that [ __ ] down as [ __ ]
that's why i don't really i don't really
i don't really [ __ ] worry too much
about hp lovecraft
literature it none of that [ __ ] would
make a good movie
it could inspire a good movie but not
enough happens in it
it's all atmosphere and most of his
stories are very very short for sure
and he refers to things that were scary
that happened
obliquely he'll mention something and
never mention it again
you're like wait what was that you could
make a whole movie on just that
mentioning something yeah some elder
forgotten god that
drove you [ __ ] crazy and you know
something that's indescribable you know
and you're like
what are you talking about you know so
but that's really what a lot of his
stories
were that's what i was saying when they
made this one
so what that it's kind of based on a a a
story
you the best h.b lovecraft movies
they've added so much and taken so much
liberties
the stories the liberties basically that
whole
the whole movie that you're watching
they're taking liberties
it's just it's inspired by something
that he mentioned
yeah and it's got love crafty and
characters in it and
monsters in it he he was a one-man
mcu okay yeah and i think that's kind of
why a lot of people adapt to stuff too
is because a lot of his stories and
stuff it's a mythos it's
you know it's interconnected so just
like they did like for example like they
did with dagon
where it's not so much based on the
story dagon it's based on shadow over
and's mouth yeah the idea of shadow
but it's sort of based on like the god
dagon as well but they kind of like
combined some [ __ ] in there
right which they didn't do so much with
this one like i said this one
it's almost kind of like they took the
germ of the story the unnamable which
like i said is only it took me
literally 20 minutes to read it it's
very very short and basically it's just
two guys telling each other
a story and then uh oh like the thing
that we were telling the story about
attacked us
the end um so that's pretty much it and
it took that
and then it fused it into almost like a
teenage
slasher monster movie kind of thing and
that's what most of it was
which i think was why the um why the
pacing of it was so off because they
were trying to fill so much time
up so it's like it's to me the movie's
not that long i think it's only like 90
minutes or 89 minutes or something
but it seemed much longer because it
seemed like there were huge like
20-minute chunks of the movie
where it was just like the characters
who weren't all that interesting
wandering around the inside of this
house yeah um
with flashlights and being like hey
wendy hey
you know where's this person and yeah
like everybody just thinks so it
so you can tell there's like a really
really lot of padding because you can
tell that they
really like they put most of the effort
and the money into the gore
and the monster and then they didn't
really think about how they were going
to fill the rest of the story
yeah which is kind of crazy because it
didn't have to be that way production
quality was good enough
yeah it's not a shitty looking movie no
uh the actors were good enough
the problem was the script it needed a
couple more story elements in there they
had a badass monster
that should have been through most of
the [ __ ] movie yeah they waited too
long to show yeah
think about this that was a female demon
that the way it looked that would have
been great in a gothic nightclub
it had titties it had two it had to it
wasn't wearing any clothes you got
teenage guys watching this
wait a minute something's missing here
sex is gonna happen somehow
all right that never happened all right
they they could have
there should have been a couple
different subplots where it was a
it was a demon that was a threat and
then maybe you
you somehow flips and it protects you
against something else and it gets
punished
kind of like something about a dunwich
horror remember that book the guy with
the goat legs and then in fact
what was it his brother comes out and
it's an invisible thing with suction
cups and a big face on top
something like that but there was more
than one monster
and uh sex almost happened i mean this
is damn
teenagers watching this and there was
another problem this is miss katonic
university these are students right but
they're
dressed like a [ __ ]
anglo-saxon american biffy and jody
[ __ ] college dude's gonna hold a
paranormal university has dudes wearing
eyesight and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] sweaters with a sweater
draped over their shoulder even back in
the 80s i mean that [ __ ] was
obviously yuppy and tacky even back then
and it was more like something your
parents would want you to wear
that that wasn't what a college student
would actually wear but i feel like
there was a lot
when whenever they were in the 80s and
they wanted to show like a frat boy
that's kind of like what they would show
that was like a frat boy uniform even
though i'm pretty sure frat boys didn't
even wear that you never saw that
you never [ __ ] saw just said the
movies just in the [ __ ] movies
because it's like here i'm going to
drape this sweater over my shoulder so
it's like ta-dah you know
and if you're in a paranormal university
you think it would be [ __ ]
in the 80s you would think well [ __ ]
it'd be goths and spooky [ __ ]
there they were going to the paranormal
university
i mean you think it almost seemed like
in this movie because like every time i
see a lovecraft adaptation because i've
seen
like a couple of good ones i've never
seen like the perfect
uh lovecraft adaptation i don't think it
exists um
unless it kind of does its own thing
with it probably you know reanimator is
probably the closest
and you know that took a lot of
liberties as well but it's like i always
feel like there's so much untapped
potential
yeah you know what i'm saying there's
just so much [ __ ] you can do
because i feel like in this one they
went to the trouble of filming
like a lot of scenes like on this
college campus and calling it miskatonic
university
i mean i know that college wasn't like a
huge plot point in there
but you're showing it you might as well
do something but you're showing it so
it's like you could have
i mean i don't have it has doesn't have
to go full hogwarts or anything like
that
but you could definitely have that type
of vibe to it
yeah and here's the thing miskatonic
university in the literature
the way it's talked about you're
imagining this
as a place where a bunch of spooky
[ __ ] are learning about the
paranormal
what are yuppies doing in there
man yeah you're talking you're thinking
that these are people that are you know
from all around the world that are
studying or trying to figure out if
sorceries were is real
or you know what i mean if [ __ ]
vampires are real
you know or maybe they have a vampire in
there you know i mean it could be all
kinds of stuff
but it wouldn't be yale you know
or you know yale 19 [ __ ] 81 you know
it's not gonna be that
yeah like i said there's seemed like
there was a lot of missed opportunities
yeah
but you know because they were just
trying to make like a teens
or 20 somethings get killed by a monster
movie
yeah but also with like like a little
sprinkling of like lovecraft on top
yeah you know what i mean now i have
heard they did make a sequel to this
um called the unnamable two uh the
statement of randolph carter
and i've heard it was way better like it
had like a bigger budget david warner
was in the [ __ ]
maybe check it out what's it called
again it's just called the unnamable two
the statement of randolph carter
and the two guys that are in this that
survived because pretty much everybody
dies
uh the two guys in this that survived
like the guy that played randolph carter
and the other guy that played uh
whatever that other fucker's name was
um the the dorky friend um because they
lived so they're in the next one too
but there's also kind of some bigger
stars in it and i haven't seen it but
like i said i've heard that it was
better than this one um this one it's
not a terrible movie i've seen like way
worse movies from around this time
period i've seen worse lovecraft
adaptations
um this one just isn't this one is more
like mediocre than anything else and it
just seems like
another thing i saw somebody talking
about this movie and they said
you know it's not a bad movie it's just
kind of like boring and sort of mediocre
the creature looks great
what they should have done was made the
creature more sympathetic
well that's what i was saying more like
a character because
like you said the the demon it's a
female demon her name is elida
and she had she has like a tragic
backstory she's born she's like locked
up in this house like her
warlock dad or whoever the [ __ ] it was
or uncle i don't remember
and these like made spells like to keep
her in there like to keep her from
getting out she's just like staring out
this window
so it's like you could have made you
could have done something with that
yeah the problem is the script yeah you
could have done something with that and
then not have her just like get killed
by somebody shaking branches
out yeah ridiculous and yeah maybe she
could have started off in a bet as a bag
of it maybe she could have flipped
and then like it's not her fault and
then like
a romance breaks out and then you
try to save her from being a demon but
something else comes along and
starts trying to kill everybody and she
gives her life saving the man she loves
it could have been some weird [ __ ] like
that
yeah like so i mean so much potential
there's a lot of potential just thrown
away
and and it wouldn't have cost that much
more it would have just been writing
writing a different script telling a
different story and
uh tweaking the costumes at miskatonic
university
making the kids look a little bit
different they weren't kids either they
were way too old to be
college students they should have
tweaked the way they looked
or were dressed they should have looked
more like some paranormal investigators
or
goths or [ __ ] people who were wannabe
sorcerers or something like that you
know i mean there were
scientists you know at least like men in
black and [ __ ] black suits or
something you know i mean
they didn't look like that they just
looked like yuppies
yeah and like i said i kind of feel like
like i said the acting was fine the
woman that played like the hot chick in
this the character's name was wendy
yeah um she actually was quite a famous
uh
stunt woman so she'd been in like a lot
of movies before she made sure she
didn't wear a bra
yeah well and she showed her tits too at
one point so it was like
get out the whole time yeah there's a
sweater i was watching it's
obvious what they're doing i was
watching this other review of it because
she does have
um maybe this is like too much of her
she does have arielies
that are like puffy and so i was
watching this one review of it and the
dude was like
she had a titty on top of her ticket
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and i just like
just pay attention to that kind of [ __ ]
well i noticed it too it was kind of
hard not to it's cute it's cute though
i've seen other other breasts that look
like that yeah but yeah that's just
another
like variation of one of those it's not
it's not weird one of the wonderful
variations of breasts around the world
how do we always get on these [ __ ]
topics i don't know the bigger they get
though the less that
the less they have that the more that
goes away stretches out
[Laughter]
then then you end up with the t saucers
[Laughter]
tom's got nomenclature
our female subscribers our female
cooking page
patrons want me to actually do a whole
show on teddy's
talking about he's a titologist and i'll
just
i just i was laughing up here speaking
of which thomas's tit theory
[Laughter]
oh my god that's going to be our next
book oh man
grantham's hammer says my daughter who
is 10 told my son who is eight to calm
your tits the other day
that's funny i love that because you
know i didn't i didn't know that like
people still said that because that was
actually one of my favorite uh phrases
from back in the day because [ __ ] we
used to say that back in the 90s like we
just
made it competent but it's like
and it well it's gender neutral you can
say it to men or women because men have
tits too
they're just not as big as women
that's what it means they're still tits
it's not a it's not a
tits or tits it doesn't matter
they're still talking about but yeah so
it wasn't a succubus but it should have
been
there's a lot of things yeah they could
have done i mean like i said i know
that's not in the story but it's like it
doesn't really
you could have like even woven like two
or three because like i said randolph
carter
um was a character in some other
lovecraft stories too
so i feel like you could have like
linked all those together you could have
made the characters more interesting
instead of just like
frat boys and like these two chicks they
were taken to this haunted house
like i said it was it almost didn't seem
like like the cinematography was cool
like the inside of the house was cool
like the lighting i really liked that
like the
with the dim green lights and just like
these yellowish like candles and
flashlights and stuff that looks really
nice
but it's like i kind of feel like they
spent too much time just creeping
around this house being like you know
scaring each other one of the frat boys
getting kind of rapey with one of the
girls
like you know and [ __ ] like that and
then slowly getting picked off one by
one
like you know doing pranks on each other
and stuff i just feel like there was too
much of that going on when they could
have had like more story
in there and more character development
in there you know what i'm saying i felt
like there wasn't a lot
listen to mr roboto this he's talking
about something earlier yes they're
still talking about manly stuff he says
the more you shave
the chest the more it grows back better
not to shave it get the [ __ ] out of it
[ __ ] out it you would never make it as a
guy honestly i think gothic
lifestyle is constant shaving we don't
have [ __ ] body hair like that man
we're all ready for [ __ ] we're ready
for we're ready for [ __ ] only fans
man
like porn stars man well don't shave
it'll just grow back
get the [ __ ] out of here that's like
saying don't wipe your ass you're just
gonna [ __ ] again
just let it build up on there
[Laughter]
yeah holy [ __ ] i know uh did this film
have a good
soundtrack not so much i kind of felt
like uh the score didn't really
the score was actually kind of weird it
was a little like 80s
cheesy like not terrible but a little
bit like
thing um the the uh
song at the end was um
it kind of reminded me of like some sub
lost boys type [ __ ]
like something that like they were gonna
put in the lost boys they're like nah
it's just we
we can't believe that they just threw it
away and then somebody else picked it up
you're talking about a movie that was
generally on par
generally on par with like um
from beyond and reanimator but with a
little bit of with
probably with half that budget i would
probably think
like imagine if ed wood was directing
there was con
imagine if ed wood had money you said
imagine this when we were watching it
you said imagine if ed wood
had money and directed castle freak yeah
that's kind of
what you're like although castle freak
was awesome right
plus it had jeffrey it had it had kind
of a
corny edward
feel to the dialogue yeah the dialogue
was real
yeah and the edit where the edit was
like something edward would do
not like not like bat [ __ ] weird but a
lot of the stuff was just
unnatural yeah it was unnatural yes
stilted that's a good word for it and it
was all
it was like real um yeah it was real
typical
like of 80s slasher movies you know you
come in the house
it's not funny you guys you're playing a
prank on me let's do this then
it's like [ __ ] that normal people
wouldn't say but it wasn't a [ __ ] movie
no it wasn't like i said i think it's
worse it's worse sin was
mediocrity i kind of feel like and the
mediocrity came from the script
yeah i don't think it was anything to do
like i said the creature looked great
right and the in the edit was part of it
too
when the first couples the first two
couples go into things and get
slaughtered
there's about twice as much as you
actually need
in there yeah ought to cut five ten
minutes out all that
this movie would probably flow a lot
better with about 15 minutes of it cut
out
and certain things re-edited because
there's a lot of [ __ ] you don't need
for this story yeah you might actually
just be able to edit some [ __ ] out of
this and make it go a little bit faster
and make it
like speed would probably be a lot
better
because like i said there's a really lot
of padding of just like the couples oh
let's separate and those hey let's sneak
around and scare them hey
looks like you don't need any of that
stuff or like people just walking around
with flashlights and whatnot
with a choice forever with a tight edit
this movie would probably be twice as
good
but like you said i kind of feel like
the story
um is kind of thin yeah and should have
been expanded right like they had that
whole mythology there which is from the
original story about this demon and that
was born
like locked and there's that's a great
[ __ ] story you can do a lot with that
yeah where it missed out was that
the demon should have been a full-on
character it doesn't say a single word
it just screams yeah she just screams
and it doesn't do a whole lot
and you just they just [ __ ] it up they
gave it away they had a good character
right there
you could have told a [ __ ] wild ass
tale with that thing as a character
but for some reason they didn't go that
way i mean they paid for the suit why
didn't they use it
yeah but the the woman in it couldn't
act
looked like she was doing good to me she
had a nice rack
oh man teenage boys nice boobs
nice legs and [ __ ] the hair growing
on it was cut to where it looked kind of
like bell bottoms and [ __ ]
and the way she has the movement she was
an interesting character that [ __ ]
teenage boys are like yeah
yeah oh you know that's gonna [ __ ] me
you know
that's looking weird oh no i have the
weirdest one
[Laughter]
you know but maybe not yeah i'm running
as fast as i can
i mean i did like that she was like you
know tearing people's hearts out and
tearing heads off and stuff that was
neat
but yeah you're right it would have been
better if it was like a succubus
thing but like i said i would have liked
it better if she was also more of a
sympathetic character
because she i mean she didn't like ask
to be born like that no she shouldn't
she could have been dangerous
but then had another side to her that
was redeeming
yeah you know what i mean like for the
right guy she was down
and she she fell in love with one dude
you know what i mean
that that it was right there in their
[ __ ] face
because then you could get a whole 20
minutes of that
yeah that would have been better than
just oh yeah frat boys wandering around
the house with flashlights
exactly and it didn't say anything see
it should have said a bunch of cool [ __ ]
yeah
i mean i guess from a standpoint it's
like you know if she was
just raised as a monster and locked in
an attic
by a warlock and who never really liked
talked to her or anything i guess you
she never learned to talk but still
i mean just love craft though man you
could like i said you could
like put so many stories together you
could like we were really good
this is a lovecraft and she's a demon
she can contact the netherworld she's
talking to demons and ghosts and gods
so just because there is supernatural
[ __ ] in here the necronomicon does make
an appearance
exactly and there's all kinds of [ __ ]
about [ __ ] summoning demons
and [ __ ] talking to the dead and all
kinds of weird and extra dimensional
[ __ ]
making candles come on maybe just
because
just because she has been locked and
trapped in the walls of that house
doesn't mean that she has
access to the [ __ ] lovecraftians
demonic internet say yeah she can talk
to these other demons
see so she should have been like real
wise
and maybe trying to make a breakthrough
and take over the world there's all
kinds of [ __ ] you could have done just
with dialogue
and story to really
he should have had me on the team i
wrote the whole thing out we'd have
worked it out and
and made that a real character and got
another 20 or 30 minutes of really good
material and then this movie would have
been remembered
the reason why it wasn't remembered is
not because it's [ __ ]
it's okay movie the way it was shot and
everything it's just that it's
there's not a lot of story there it's
not that interesting yeah like i said i
think it's main sin was just mediocrity
mediocre uh script but i think like
easily the creature is the best thing
about it like the look of the creature
the creature looks really great they
should have milked that
creature dry i mean they're showing it
they're showing it fully
on the cover they should have milked
that [ __ ] yeah so it's like why
it's like behind it yeah don't bother
having suspense because i feel like for
the first like hour of this movie
right you just kind of see the shadow of
it you don't know what it looks like
yeah and then they blow it right there
on the cover
yeah it's a photograph of it which that
was the only thing about the movie so
there should have been a whole movie of
that
yeah you know well like you said it
could have been a west character he's
trying to rationalize
the titties well you have to understand
something
even demons enjoy mammary glands
[Laughter]
we can't destroy a demon with titties
like that
you know she's hot even in hell
it should have been anything you know
had this
had this been like the same team that
done re-animator
or from beyond that [ __ ] would have been
hypersexual because those movies were
and crazy and crazy herbert wesley would
be like stand back
hand me the brawl
he's trying to battle this [ __ ]
female demon remember wes would have
said you know
run i got this i got this you all
yeah taught me the condoms
just in case now that i'm thinking of of
the
of the normal looking girls puffy
areolas i was thinking how cool would it
have been if the demons had had the
titties or the demon head out of titties
but then like other littler titties pop
out of the bigger titties
and then they have like mouths on them
or something it could have been tit
warfare
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] gets jealous of the demon's
rags and starts makes a comment
you know what i mean well see i thought
that's where it was going because
because the two girls like one of them
is posited is like hotter than the other
one or at least like more popular than
the other yeah they're about the same
and they're about the same level of
hotness i mean i'm not a dude so i don't
know
but they looked about the same level of
hotness the one had worse hair than the
other one but it was the 80s everybody
had bad hair
so but there's kind of like a little
plot i don't even know if i'd call it a
plot point it was just kind of like a
couple like thrown away lines
where the girl who wasn't quite as
popular
was she supposed to be an exchange
student or something she had like
germany no she was french right right no
germany right
i thought she was french i think i don't
know dude dude said you're from france
she goes no i'm from germany oh okay
she was from a swiss boarding school
wasn't she oh right yeah oh yeah they
said she lived all over i don't know
i can't remember what her accent was she
wasn't american
so so she just came there and i guess
like she has this other chick that's
like trying to like school her like you
can't date freshman you can't do this if
you want to be like popular and
we're gonna like pledge the sororities
or whatever and
so there's like a kind of she makes a
couple of plot of
you know kind of throwaway comments
during the movie that it's like why does
everybody
like she ask the the dorky dude it's
like why does everybody like wendy so
much
is it her big tits but her tits aren't
really that big i mean they're
they're just like regular sized tips
decent b
yeah they they weren't like yeah i think
it would that would have played better
if like the woman had like
gigantic tits and then you'd be like
then that would have made more
it was an illusion because but well the
girl that they're huge
the girl is saying to that girl
their tits are about the same size i
mean maybe maybe the
the the german girls were a little bit
smaller but not really
bigger they might yeah it was like
shorter everybody had like
baggy sweaters on because 88 i had a
feeling that she was actually
better built because the tall one she
was the one that they're talking about
was tall
and thin she had skinny legs and stuff
she was good-looking
she wasn't real shapely by today's
standards you know what i mean just kind
of you know how it was back in the 80s
skinny girls were in
yeah i think it was just holdovers from
the 70s it was
pre-j low pretty booty
as far as white guys were concerned we
had not been introduced into the booty
game
it took a while but uh
i think that was more a thing of
directors though
and what directors thought was attract
because they were older
yeah maybe that's what it was because uh
that's not what was selling in the porn
[ __ ] scene and the porn and
in the porn scene the you know
women that were stacked were the top
porn stars not skinny
i mean they had skinny ones but most of
them were just pretty stacked
with you know good okay like anita
hartley yeah
at that time she was like well top ones
and she she worked out you know she had
a fantastic lower body
for most of her life she still looks
good she's still importing that woman
and she's gonna be 60 something yeah
she's got to be she's still not older
yeah still works out and stuff zilla's
the movie needs to be made says kind of
titzzillas yeah
tit warfare um i said i said tina heart
not nina hartley nina hartley yeah yeah
okay you said it right
i thought i said tina yeah but yeah so
so even the fact that they brought that
up a couple of times
um actually just makes it more like it's
just like why didn't they
you know kind of incorporate that into
like the demon
kind of [ __ ] too like they could have
done that it was just a bunch of missed
opportunities yeah
for some reason somebody got stuck on
that script and that was the script they
were gonna go with
and you would think working on this
thing you would see a bunch of missed
opportunities to tell to tell a better
story and have a bunch more
in it but maybe they're just having a
hard time getting the damn movie done
yeah that might have been with it i
don't know what's going on behind the
scenes
yeah there may have been time
limitations or something
it's yeah and that's the thing it just
seems like like i said it sounds like
we're [ __ ] on it and i'm not really
it's like it's it's it's fine it was a
fine maybe
it's just it could have been but it
could have been like really good
especially and
you know and especially because it's
kind of disappointing because there's
not a lot of great
lovecraft adaptations so like every time
one comes out
i mean i really i honestly i really
really liked color out of space
um i think that's one of the most love
crafty
like at least as far as the visuals were
concerned but i really really like dagon
too like dagon to me
yeah um seems the most love crafty in
the sense that it's the most like
lovecraft's uh pros to me
all they had to do is throw out some of
the filler and have a script that had a
couple extra scenes that did some [ __ ]
and this movie would have been
remembered maybe with from beyond up
there you know
as you know similar yeah
it would have been better than castle
freak if it if had if they'd done what i
said
yeah and i love castle phrases yeah
this was if i had to say like which
lovecraft
adaptation this was most like it's most
like castle freak but castle freak is
like way way better
yeah just in terms of storytelling yeah
and edit yeah just technically a little
better but like i said
this one had a lot of potential a lot of
potential
they just walked away from yeah
kind of a shame yeah but you know but
it's worth seeing it is if you look you
know i don't you know
if you're into lovecraft's stuff then
yeah you'll see what i'm talking about
yeah if you want to be
if you're it's for a collection you know
you want to buy it for a collection yeah
i did
just just say yeah i got it mr robotics
especially if it has a good sequel
you said it has a good sequel i've heard
that the sequel is way way better
okay um but i don't know because i've
never seen it right
but i've heard from multiple like other
reviewers that the sequel is way better
okay um but but i don't know all right
it used to be i think like back in when
this came out on dvd
uh in the uk it was always packaged
with the sequel so both of them came in
one pack
khan says dagon needs a remake i
disagree no dagon as good as it is
it's good just like it is what it needs
is it needs something like a sequel
yeah you could do something that was
more like the story day gone because
like i said the movie dagon is more
shadow over in smuth as well that is you
could have something like dagon
happening in another location of the
world but it's
basically something like that and then
you find out more about the damn dagon
as a god that would be really good yeah
mr roboto said
what was the deal with miskatonic
university is it real
no and or no it's not or did lovecraft
go there no it's a
it's a fictional economic yeah it's a
fictional university and much like the
necronomicon which was also a lovecraft
invention
um he just made things up so he could
refer to them like
yeah and you refer to them a lot
universe stories so
like i said that's why they called the
lovecraft mythos if
because he came up with arkham is like a
fake
town he invented this whole town it's
based on a real town but it's not a real
town
you know miskatonic university all this
the necronomicon all that stuff is just
stuff that he
mad arab yeah yeah abdul al-hazrad yeah
yeah he made all that stuff up that's
like i said he was a one-man mcu
yeah and over over a bunch of stories
he'd refer to things and refer
back to certain gods old ones great old
ones
uh what else um
he referred to gods like narla hotep
some ancient egyptian monster god well
and two there's
um people that were contemporaries of
h.p lovecraft that were friends of his
that also wrote for wield
weird tales around the same time period
also picked up aspects of his story and
wrote their own stories in it
so there's actually also an extended
lovecraft universe with other authors
adding their [ __ ]
which they still do nowadays but they
were even doing that when he was alive
now john carpenter when he made the
thing
john carpenter's the thing
that's probably a lovecraft story
because the thing is basically doing
what lovecraft
described the shag off as doing which
was a slave race to the great old ones
and these were [ __ ] interplanetary
aliens who had enslaved another race of
like a thing like an amoeba
that they used as slaves but they were
mindless
but they they could absorb things and
mimic them
and one time somehow long millions of
years of service it got
it absorbed a creature that had a brain
and it became self-aware and they
they they shared a brain
data between how to make a brain between
them all and the collective became
conscious and overthrew the the great
old ones
and that they took all their technology
and stuff
so what landed out there might have been
a spaceship of a shag off
using technology that it got over the u
over time
so that might have been a shag off yeah
that's that a lot of people don't
realize that but that the thing may have
been a shag off
kanavasan says that lighthouse dude
banging that mermaid was also a good
movie if you're not
talking he said i can't remember the
name if it's not if you're not talking
about the lighthouse the robert eggers
movie
then you might be talking about there
was a movie called
cold skin that i think was about
a dude in a lighthouse and a mermaid so
that might be the one that i'm thinking
of
yeah i don't know because i think i saw
that one that might be on shutter
uh but yeah so if you want to watch like
i said if you're a lovecraft completist
and you just are interested in seeing
like another adaptation that maybe
got a little bit forgotten about then
this is on amazon prime it might also be
on
to be like i said it's not great but
it's watchable um you know it's just
i just thought it was kind of you know
meh yeah that's all but like i said a
lot of a lot of lovecraft adaptations
were this is kind of one of the worst
ones but
you know there's there's not a lot of
great ones you know what i'm saying
so um are are we done that's it okay
he's got to get back to fixing the
garage all right so yeah we will be back
tomorrow night for our drunken side
track show show
man we got to go buy some booze yeah
tomorrow uh yeah because i could think
we're completely out
uh so yeah and we're gonna do uh the
full-on manly man debate
and then we'll see how it goes from
there because like i said i didn't want
to like waste all the good manly man to
be honest
if i can keep that [ __ ] up all night
well it says we can go on to other
topics it's a sidetrack show
you know we don't have to that doesn't
have to be the topic for the whole thing
all right so uh we will see you guys uh
for the side track show tomorrow night 5
p.m eastern standard time
have a good rest of your day and we'll
see you guys tomorrow
bye